so Krypton is one of the noble gases
it's not very reactive but it does react
with the element fluorine Jim Turner who
was my supervisor when I did my
doctorate was one of the was the first
person to discover that fluorine could
react with Krypton but even that
reaction requires quite bright lights to
dissipate the bond between the fluorine
atoms to get them to react but Krypton
can also be used in lasers
when mixtures of Krypton and the
fluorine containing compound can be used
to generate very bright and pulses or
intense pulses of ultraviolet light some
years ago we had the professor here who
bought a really big Krypton fluoride
laser and when he switched it on and the
beam hit the wall it burnt a hole right
through the wall so he knew where to
make the hole to get his beam into the
next lab